Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Speaking of Psychology is a podcast for anyone with an interest in the science of psychology. We talk to psychological researchers, practitioners, and educators about any and every aspect of psychology and its application to the world around us. Dr. Emma Williams teaches psychology. at the University of Bristol in the United Kingdom. Her research interests include understanding how people perceive, consider, and make decisions about risk in relation to emerging technologies and online activities. In particular, she studies how these judgments may be influenced by a range
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人金·米尔斯。《心理学谈话》是一档面向所有对心理学科学感兴趣的听众的播客。我们与心理学研究人员、从业者和教育工作者探讨心理学的方方面面及其在现实世界中的应用。艾玛·威廉姆斯博士在英国布里斯托大学教授心理学。她的研究兴趣包括了解人们如何感知、思考和做出有关新兴技术及在线活动的风险决策。特别是，她研究了这些判断如何受到一系列
of real-life factors. She also studies how best to help people understand their risks online so they can make informed choices, and she explores how and why people are susceptible to online scams like fishing and other situations that put their security and privacy at risk. Thanks for joining us today, Dr. Williams. No problem. Happy to. So let's start by talking about the reasons why people fall for these kinds of dirty tricks. Well, I think there's a little bit of a misconception sometimes that these things are obvious
现实因素的影响。她还研究如何最好地帮助人们了解在线风险，以便他们做出明智的选择，并探索人们为何以及如何容易受到网络诈骗（如钓鱼攻击）及其他危及个人安全和隐私的情况的影响。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，威廉姆斯博士。没问题，很高兴能来。那么，让我们先从人们为何会掉进这些卑劣伎俩的陷阱谈起吧。嗯，我认为有时人们存在一种误解，觉得这些骗局显而易见，
to spot. So with fishing emails, people tend to think about what's known as the Nigerian prints kind of scams. Oh, it's really obvious. Someone's clearly offering me a million pounds to move some money into my account. And the reality is that that's not what scams actually are anymore necessarily. So that's an aspect. But the advent of technology is meant that they can actually create fake pages, fake emails that look very much like the real thing. So they can use particular logos. They can have email addresses that pretty much look identical to the genuine thing. So it's very hard for people to actually spot the difference.
很容易被发现。比如钓鱼邮件，人们往往会想到所谓的“尼日利亚王子”之类的骗局。哦，那太明显了。有人显然在提议给我一百万英镑，让我把钱转到我的账户里。但现实情况是，现在的骗局未必都是那样的。这是一个方面。但技术的进步意味着他们实际上可以创建看起来非常逼真的虚假页面和虚假邮件。他们可以使用特定的标志，可以使用看起来与真实地址几乎一模一样的电子邮件地址。所以人们很难真正发现其中的区别。
And obviously we have limited kind of cognitive abilities to be able to actually do multiple things at once. So when you're checking your emails, someone's talking to you in the background, you've got to kind of be able to spot these tiny little errors, if you like, in that information, while simultaneously doing other things that are going on in your daily life. So from your research, what do you know about the characteristics of people who are likely to fall for these scams? And people tend to think that it's senior citizens who always succumb, but I bet that's not true. No, not really, yeah.
显然，我们同时处理多项任务的认知能力是有限的。所以当你查看邮件时，背景里有人在跟你说话，你必须在处理日常生活中其他事情的同时，还要能发现信息中那些细微的错误。那么，根据您的研究，您对那些容易上当受骗的人的特征有什么了解吗？人们往往认为总是老年人会中招，但我敢说那不是真的。不，确实不是。
I think as well people are generally quite confident themselves that they won't fall for scams, but obviously then people do, and they were the ones who potentially were quite confident that they wouldn't be the type of person. So it just highlights that anybody can fall victim to scams. You also do tend to see scams that are tailored to potentially particular demographics.
我认为人们通常对自己不会上当受骗相当自信，但显然人们还是会中招，而这些人可能之前非常自信自己不会是那种人。这恰恰说明任何人都有可能成为诈骗的受害者。你确实也会看到针对特定人群量身定制的骗局。
So, for instance, people who are currently looking for love in online dating sites would be the target potentially of online romance, scams. You can have older adults who potentially have got retirement income might be targeted by investment scams if they've got lump sums coming out of pensions and things like that. In the UK, we see a lot of younger adults being targeted by things related to rental properties and things like that. So in terms of susceptibility, it's probably less about the characteristic type of person who's vulnerable to these things. And more about the fact that the scammers know what certain
例如，目前在在线约会网站上寻找爱情的人，可能会成为网络浪漫诈骗的目标。老年人如果拥有退休收入，在领取养老金等大额款项时，可能会成为投资诈骗的目标。在英国，我们看到很多年轻人成为与租赁房产等相关骗局的目标。因此，就易受骗性而言，这可能与个人的性格特征关系不大，更多是因为骗子知道某些
types of people might be interested in, so they might target particular demographics with kind of tailored scam kind of techniques, if you like. And also, the fact is that anyone can be vulnerable to these types of things. So if we're in a hurry, if we're distracted, they tend to know just how to turn on those buttons. So they use quite well-established social influence techniques of Chaldini, who's a, I think, well-known psychologist from the 50s and 60s. Yes, Robert Chaldini, sure. So things linked to authorities, they'll claim to be from known institutions. things people are familiar with, or that have a degree of, I suppose, a degree of authority about them. So banks, the police have been kind of mimicked in some email scams and things.
类型的人可能感兴趣，所以他们可能会用所谓的“量身定制”的诈骗手段来针对特定人群。而且事实是，任何人都有可能受到这些骗局的影响。所以，如果我们匆忙行事，或者分心了，他们往往知道如何触动那些按钮。他们使用了相当成熟的社会影响力技术，这些技术来自西奥迪尼，我想他是一位50年代和60年代著名的心理学家。是的，罗伯特·西奥迪尼，没错。所以，与权威相关的事情，他们会声称来自知名机构，人们熟悉的事物，或者我认为具有一定权威性的事物。比如银行、警察，在一些电子邮件诈骗中就被模仿过。
They'll also do a sense of urgency. There's always a deadline. There's usually something to make someone panic. So it's very much like, if you don't update your account within the next 24 hours, you're going to lose access to something. And obviously, people don't want to lose access to an account that they actually genuinely use and genuinely need. so it can make them panic, and then they rely on different types of information, kind of processing when they make their decisions.
他们还会制造一种紧迫感。总有一个截止日期。通常会有一些事情让人们感到恐慌。比如，如果你不在接下来的24小时内更新你的账户，你就会失去对某项服务的访问权限。显然，人们不想失去他们真正使用且真正需要的账户访问权限。这会让他们感到恐慌，然后他们在做决定时就会依赖不同类型的信息处理方式。
They tend to rely on these kind of mental shortcuts and heuristics, rather than kind of taking a step back and thinking through, is it possible that this is not a genuine communication? They tend to rely on the fact that people might panic and instantaneously respond to something, or at least some kind of emotional reaction that will just maximise the chances that someone's going to click on that email before they've actually had a chance to go,
他们倾向于依赖这些心理捷径和启发式方法，而不是退后一步思考：这封邮件会不会不是真实的通信？他们倾向于利用人们可能会恐慌并立即做出反应的心理，或者至少利用某种情绪反应，从而最大限度地提高人们在还没来得及思考之前就点击那封邮件的几率，
actually, you know, there was a little error there and that is a little bit suspicious. So what can consumers do to protect themselves? Definitely always take a bit of time before responding to things. They do very much focus on worrying people, on panicking them and wanting them to respond fast. So if you feel that you're feeling pressured to respond to something in any situation, whether that's online or even face-to-face or on the phone, then actually just take a step back and think, why would that be the case? I'm feeling pressured, so we almost need to kind of take a moment and actually think, is it possible that this isn't legitimately what it's claiming to be? We tend to assume that things are truthful, they're
比如，“其实那里有个小错误，这有点可疑”。那么消费者可以做些什么来保护自己呢？绝对要在回复任何事情之前花点时间。他们确实非常专注于让人们担心、恐慌，并希望人们快速做出反应。所以，如果你在任何情况下感到有压力需要回复某事，无论是在线、面对面还是通过电话，那么请退后一步思考：为什么会这样？我感到有压力，所以我们几乎需要花点时间思考一下：这会不会不是它所声称的那样？我们倾向于假设事物是真实的、
trustworthy, so it's being a little bit more suspicious, which is a sad thing to say, but it is the reality. And also asking someone else who's away from the situation, whether that is a friend or a neighbour, or whether that's actually contacting the company who's claiming to contact you via another means, another route, because sometimes you can feel sucked into the situation. And once you're in it, you can kind of panic a little bit and not spot things. Whereas other people who are outside of that, they're not feeling that emotion, might immediately say, that doesn't sound right, actually. And it can give you a little bit more confidence that that's actually not correct
值得信赖的，所以保持一点怀疑态度，虽然说出来很遗憾，但这确实是现实。此外，询问一下局外人，无论是朋友还是邻居，或者通过其他方式联系那个声称在联系你的公司，因为有时你会感觉被卷入了某种情境。一旦身处其中，你可能会有点恐慌而无法发现问题。而那些局外人，因为没有那种情绪，可能会立即说：“这听起来不对劲。”这能让你更有信心，意识到那确实是不正确的，
and you shouldn't respond to it. Have you done any research into these scams where people are able to actually hold you hostage and demand ransom. You won't get your photos back. We now own everything on your hard drive. Ransomware. Yes. I've not done any direct research on ransomware,
你不应该回复它。你是否做过关于那些能够真正扣押你并勒索赎金的骗局的研究？比如“你拿不回你的照片了，我们现在拥有你硬盘上的一切”。勒索软件。是的。我没有直接研究过勒索软件，
but obviously what you have to remember with ransomware is it's kind of the end state. So it's how have they got that onto your machine potentially. So if your machine has become infected, usually that's started with something like a fishing email. You've visited a website potentially that's had what's called, I think it's drive-by download of malware. So if you've visited certain suspicious websites. So it's all about how that's originally got there.
但显然，关于勒索软件，你必须记住的是，这是一种最终状态。所以关键在于他们是如何将其植入你的机器的。如果你的机器被感染了，通常是从钓鱼邮件之类的东西开始的。你可能访问了一个所谓的“路过式下载”恶意软件的网站。所以，这一切都取决于它最初是如何进入的。
So you don't want that ransomware on your machine. If you are in a situation where you have ransomware on your machine, obviously that's where you really want to try and contact some kind of technical authority or law enforcement agency that might be able to help you. I'm not sure what they are in the US. In the UK, we have very particular things called action fraud, which is a police reporting for online fraud and things like that, and they can actually potentially help in what to do
所以你肯定不希望勒索软件进入你的机器。如果你确实处于机器中了勒索软件的情况，显然，这时你真的需要尝试联系某种技术权威机构或执法部门，他们或许能提供帮助。我不确定在美国是哪些机构。在英国，我们有非常具体的机构叫“Action Fraud”，这是专门针对网络欺诈等行为的警察举报平台，他们实际上可能在
if you're a victim of a ransomware attack in particular. But it's really about being careful and avoiding that happening by not clicking on things, not opening attachments to emails that you're not expecting that might actually contain the malware that can lead to attacks like that. What do you see as the next wave? I mean, as you're looking at these kinds of scams and the way people behave around them.
如果你成为勒索软件攻击的受害者时，能提供如何处理的帮助。但关键在于要小心，通过不点击不明链接、不打开意料之外的邮件附件来避免这种情况发生，因为这些附件可能包含导致此类攻击的恶意软件。你认为下一波浪潮是什么？我是说，当你观察这些骗局以及人们围绕它们的行为时。
I mean, how do we stay one step ahead of the bad guys? That's always really hard because unfortunately the bad guys are quite good at anticipating how people are behaving. In terms of staying one step ahead, we're trying to educate people as much as possible and make people aware that online, the risks are just as great as they are offline.
我是说，我们如何才能领先坏人一步？这总是非常困难，因为不幸的是，坏人非常擅长预测人们的行为。在领先一步方面，我们正试图尽可能多地教育人们，让人们意识到在线风险和线下风险一样大。
Obviously, now people tend to lock their doors if they're worried about their security. And it's about trying to get that mindset of keeping your life secure, if you like, in terms of online activities. So this kind of stuff is always developing. Unfortunately, scammers do tend to evolve in line with kind of the victims that they're targeting. So if people become more suspicious of certain types of things or stop responding to
显然，现在人们如果担心安全，往往会锁好门。这关乎尝试建立一种保持生活安全的思维方式，在在线活动方面也是如此。所以这类事情总是在发展。不幸的是，骗子确实倾向于随着他们针对的受害者而进化。所以如果人们对某些类型的事情变得更加怀疑，或者停止回复
certain types of scams, and they're probably going to try something else. So it is going to be a constant battle of educating yourself about the scams that are out there. there are a lot of awareness, online awareness campaigns and things like that. There are a lot of groups and bodies that are trying to kind of help people. So keep yourself educated, make yourself aware. And we are very much trying to obviously not only identify how these scams work so we can better educate people about them.
某些类型的骗局，他们可能会尝试其他方法。所以，不断学习了解现有的骗局将是一场持久战。有很多意识提升活动，在线意识宣传活动等等。有很多团体和机构正试图帮助人们。所以要保持学习，提高意识。我们不仅在努力识别这些骗局是如何运作的，以便更好地教育人们。
But as research is trying to anticipate where they might go next with emerging technologies, obviously wearables, other types of devices coming out, then potentially the crimes that relate to those are going to develop in the future. So we're just trying to anticipate them a little bit and building better security features around those. So how do you secure your wearables? I mean, are there programs now where you can do that? The organisations that create these things are now being pressured to build in security by default. Because the idea is that traditionally they've relied on people protecting themselves.
而且作为研究人员，我们正试图预测随着新兴技术的发展，它们可能会走向何方。显然，可穿戴设备和其他类型设备的出现，意味着未来与这些相关的犯罪也会发展。所以我们只是试图提前预测它们，并围绕这些设备构建更好的安全功能。那么你如何保护你的可穿戴设备？我是说，现在有可以做到这一点的程序吗？创造这些产品的组织现在正受到压力，要求默认内置安全性。因为传统的观念是，他们依赖于人们自己保护自己。
So they'll push a product out there. and they will very much say the security really is up to you. Change your default password. Make sure you do any security updates, etc. And obviously putting quite a lot of onus on the consumer to make those decisions, whereas there's a bit of a movement now to try and pressure the manufacturers to make security better in their products before they're released, to build in what's known as security by default,
所以他们会推出产品，并且会非常明确地表示，安全确实取决于你自己。更改默认密码。确保进行任何安全更新等。显然，这把相当大的责任推给了消费者去做出这些决定，而现在有一种趋势，试图向制造商施压，要求他们在产品发布前提高安全性，构建所谓的“默认安全”，
so that in theory, the consumer shouldn't have to worry about the fact that they need to do all these things. it should just do it automatically as a default. So hopefully if they do that, then. But who knows whether they will. Challenge. Have we lost the battle already, though? I mean, you know, every day we find out about Cambridge Analytica
这样理论上，消费者就不必担心需要做所有这些事情。它应该在默认情况下自动完成。所以希望如果他们这样做的话，那么……但谁知道他们是否会这样做呢。挑战。不过我们是不是已经输掉了这场战斗？我是说，你知道，我们每天都能听到关于剑桥分析公司
and how many Facebook accounts have been compromised and another department stores tells us that 500,000 credit cards have been stolen. I mean, what can we do? I don't think we've lost the battle already. what's almost happened is that all this technology rolled out, all this new forms of data, new forms of interacting rolled out, things like security weren't really considered, things like privacy weren't really considered. Obviously, it was a new way of people communicating with each other, so people just weren't aware of the risks around it that much.
以及有多少Facebook账户被泄露的消息，另一家百货公司告诉我们有50万张信用卡被盗。我是说，我们能做什么？我不认为我们已经输掉了这场战斗。几乎发生的情况是，所有这些技术推出，所有这些新形式的数据、新形式的互动推出时，安全之类的事情并没有被真正考虑，隐私之类的事情也没有被真正考虑。显然，这是一种人们相互交流的新方式，所以人们对周围的风险并没有那么了解。
And it's almost like that's now just starting to catch up. So you've had a period of time if something new has been rolled out, oh, yeah, let's have a go, let's see. And now we're suddenly starting to see all these stories because obviously the criminals are a way. that they can exploit certain things or other people are aware they can exploit certain things. And I think we're almost now at a point where all of these risks are now circulating and people are aware of them. So Cambridge Analytica, that's quite a good example of something that's massively in the media led to all these stories in newspapers and stuff, oh, do you need your Facebook account?
这几乎就像现在才开始赶上。所以你有一段时间，如果有什么新东西推出，“哦，是的，让我们试试看”。现在我们突然开始看到所有这些故事，因为显然罪犯意识到他们可以利用某些东西，或者其他人意识到他们可以利用某些东西。我认为我们现在几乎到了一个所有这些风险都在传播，人们也意识到了这些风险的地步。所以剑桥分析公司就是一个很好的例子，它在媒体上引起了巨大反响，导致报纸上出现了所有这些故事，比如“你需要Facebook账户吗？”
Maybe we should stop doing Facebook. How can you secure it? So it made people very aware of the fact that actually that was data and that data that you're putting on social media is used by other people and can be used. It's been massively helpful to make people understand that actually the stuff they put online is sensitive information potentially and can be used by this. So I actually think we're almost at a point where maybe the battle was being lost a little bit, but it's almost starting to catch up again.
“也许我们应该停止使用Facebook。”你如何保护它？所以这让人们非常清楚地意识到，那确实是数据，你放在社交媒体上的数据会被其他人使用，并且可以被利用。这对于让人们理解他们放在网上的东西实际上是潜在的敏感信息，并且可以被这样利用，是非常有帮助的。所以我实际上认为我们几乎到了一个地步，也许战斗曾经输掉了一点，但现在几乎又开始赶上来了。
There's a new impetus. There's obviously a lot of regulation, focus on improving regulations and stuff like that. So, you know, how can we now have regulation that catches up with these new forms of data? So I think we're almost at a, I don't always say a tipping point, that's very strong, but a kind of turning point where it's like, okay, now the risks are very real, and people are seeing that, and we're starting to see a more societal response. So how that will play out, I don't know, but I think we're now a point where, yeah, maybe we're doing better in the battle.
有一种新的动力。显然有很多监管，重点在于改进法规等等。所以，我们现在如何才能拥有跟上这些新数据形式的监管呢？所以我认为我们几乎处于一个……我不想总是说“临界点”，那太强烈了，但处于一个转折点，就像是，“好吧，现在风险非常真实，人们看到了这一点，我们开始看到更多的社会反应。”所以这会如何发展，我不知道，但我认为我们现在处于一个……是的，也许我们在战斗中做得更好了。
I would hope. So what are you studying now? What are you looking at for the future? So we're doing a few different things. We're looking at how people perceive risks around emerging technologies, so things like autonomous vehicles, whether they actually perceive any security risks associated with that, how willing they would be to use those technologies if they became available.
我希望如此。那么你现在在研究什么？你对未来有什么展望？所以我们正在做几件不同的事情。我们正在研究人们如何感知围绕新兴技术的风险，比如自动驾驶汽车，他们是否真正感知到与之相关的任何安全风险，如果这些技术可用，他们会有多大意愿使用它们。
So we're kind of trying to understand, well, what risks are people worried about? Can we actually, almost, before these technologies get rolled out mainstream, let's actually look at how they might be, exploited or manipulated, how people perceive risks around them and almost kind of then build it, build it into the system so that we can prevent those risks almost becoming a reality. We're also doing some work around how we can better inform people around digital risks, online risks. So it's quite a technical thing to understand sometimes.
所以我们正在尝试理解，人们担心什么风险？我们能否在这些技术进入主流之前，看看它们可能如何被利用或操纵，人们如何感知周围的风险，然后几乎将其构建到系统中，这样我们就可以防止这些风险几乎成为现实。我们还在做一些关于如何更好地告知人们数字风险、在线风险的工作。所以有时这是一个相当技术性的问题。
The online world is really complicated. It's a very complex, abstract beast, really, to try and get your head around. So we're trying to look at, well, how do people want to be informed about digital risks, online risks? How can we empower them to make decisions? What kind of information do they want to know? How can we best present it to actually encourage them to really make decisions that are going to be in their best interests, I suppose. So we're very early stages trying to look at, as opposed, slightly, a conversation about how people want to be talked about their data and how we're going to be. we can better design kind of awareness interventions and things to really encourage people to engage with those materials and actually change their behaviour slightly.
在线世界真的很复杂。要理解它，它确实是一个非常复杂、抽象的野兽。所以我们正在尝试研究，人们希望如何被告知数字风险、在线风险？我们如何赋予他们做出决定的能力？他们想知道什么样的信息？我们如何最好地呈现它，以真正鼓励他们做出符合他们最大利益的决定？所以我认为我们处于非常早期的阶段，试图探讨人们希望如何被告知他们的数据，以及我们如何能更好地设计意识干预措施，真正鼓励人们参与这些材料并稍微改变他们的行为。
So they're not quite there yet? No, gosh, no, no. I think we're very early stage. So I've only just started doing this work at the University of Bristol. So I started there last November. So before then, I was at the University of Bath doing work around fishing emails and what makes people susceptible to them. So that was the stuff focused on influence techniques and whether people notice differences in, cues and what factors might affect that in the work environment and stuff. Whereas now we're very
所以他们还没到那一步？不，天哪，没有，没有。我认为我们处于非常早期的阶段。所以我才刚刚在布里斯托大学开始这项工作。所以我去年11月在那里开始。所以在那之前，我在巴斯大学做关于钓鱼邮件以及是什么让人容易受到攻击的研究。所以那是专注于影响力技术，以及人们是否注意到线索的差异，以及在工作环境中哪些因素可能影响这一点的工作。而现在我们非常
much moving into the, since I've started at the University of Bristol, moving into this, okay, how do people perceive risks? How do they consider them in relation to the online space? How do they understand them? And if they actually consider it to be quite risky, then what will actually change their behaviour? Because people are concerned about their privacy, but then they still share information. They still do things that kind of counter to what they say they care about. So it's really trying to understand how people are making those judgments. And that's something we still don't really have a grasp from, I don't think. So you said you mentioned Robert Chaldini earlier and he's done a lot around green behavior, people who are aware of the
多地转向了——自从我在布里斯托大学开始工作以来——转向了“好吧，人们如何感知风险？他们如何看待在线空间中的风险？他们如何理解它们？”如果他们确实认为这风险很大，那么什么会真正改变他们的行为？因为人们关心他们的隐私，但他们仍然分享信息。他们仍然做一些与他们所说的关心的事情背道而驰的事情。所以这真的是在试图理解人们是如何做出这些判断的。我认为我们仍然没有真正掌握这一点。所以你刚才提到了罗伯特·西奥迪尼，他在绿色行为方面做了很多工作，关于那些意识到
environment and how to make people make decisions that would be earth friendly. Is that the kind of information you're looking at? How does that apply to online behavior? Yeah, yeah, I think so. Well, in some ways there's quite a lot of parallels. So obviously when we talk about things like environmental behaviours, again, it can be something that's quite far down the line as a potential if we take climate change as a potential risk. That's something that people might not necessarily see as happening to me right now in front of me. It's a potential risk in the future. It's something that's quite abstract. It's quite big. Who knows who it will apply to or how? So it can be quite hard when people are actually making a decision in the here and now to engage in a behaviour that
环境的人，以及如何让人们做出对地球友好的决定。这是你正在研究的信息吗？这如何应用于在线行为？是的，是的，我想是这样。嗯，在某些方面有很多相似之处。所以显然当我们谈论像环境行为这样的事情时，如果我们将气候变化视为一种潜在风险，这可能是一个相当遥远的事情。这是人们未必会觉得“现在就在我面前发生”的事情。这是未来的潜在风险。这是一个相当抽象的事情。它很大。谁知道它会适用于谁或如何适用？所以当人们在此时此地做出决定时，要参与一种行为，
they want to engage in but might be counter to obviously environmental, pro-environmental behaviour, but they really want to do that. And because the other thing is quite far away and quite abstract, then maybe they won't actually make the decision that's in those best interests, hence why obviously Chaldean is interested in kind of almost nudging people into that. So there is work around how we can nudge people in a similar way in online behaviour, but it's still quite early stages. And I think we've got a slight issue in the fact that although there are a lot of similarities, so it's quite a big issue again, online risk potentially.
他们想参与但可能与显然的环境、亲环境行为背道而驰，这可能相当困难。而且因为另一件事相当遥远且相当抽象，所以也许他们不会做出符合那些最大利益的决定，这就是为什么显然西奥迪尼对几乎引导人们这样做感兴趣。所以有一些关于我们如何以类似方式引导人们进行在线行为的研究，但这仍然处于相当早期的阶段。而且我认为我们有一个轻微的问题，尽管有很多相似之处，所以这又是一个相当大的问题，潜在的在线风险。
If you decide to click on a link in an email or visit a website that might be fraudulent, whether you're going to see an immediate impact on yourself, who knows, particularly in a work environment, it might be an impact that's where, down the line, you don't really understand how it's going to work. Again, it's quite abstract. Is it going to really impact me? Potentially not. I don't understand how it will. So there's all these similar types of parallels. So I would say that we are starting to try and apply exactly the same approaches, but whilst also understanding that technology keeps changing, and that's part of the problem, because it's advancing so fast. If you look at people's behavior in one space,
如果你决定点击邮件中的链接或访问可能欺诈的网站，你是否会对自己产生直接影响，谁知道呢，特别是在工作环境中，这可能是一个影响，在未来，你并不真正理解它将如何运作。同样，它相当抽象。它真的会影响我吗？可能不会。我不明白它将如何影响。所以有所有这些相似类型的平行线。所以我认为我们开始尝试应用完全相同的方法，但同时也理解技术在不断变化，这是问题的一部分，因为它进步得太快了。如果你观察人们在一个空间的行为，
suddenly they're using a new technology, or they're using a new social media platform or even, for instance, Facebook's changed. So actually even the layout of one year might be very different to what they're doing next year. And that makes it very hard to keep up. So it's slightly different in that respect, I would say, if that makes sense. No, it does. It does. And you never know.
突然他们在使用一种新技术，或者他们在使用一个新的社交媒体平台，甚至，例如，Facebook改变了。所以实际上即使一年的布局也可能与他们明年所做的非常不同。这使得跟上步伐非常困难。所以我认为在这方面稍微有点不同，如果这说得通的话。不，说得通。说得通。而且你永远不知道。
There's a new app next week that you suddenly are enamored of and who knows what it's doing. So basic advice, change your passwords off. keep them really complicated. Don't write them down where anybody can find them. Yeah, basic things like that. Although there is advice now in the UK that actually suggests you shouldn't change your password that often anymore because it's making it very difficult to the fact that you need complicated passwords is important. So if you're also requiring people to change them really often, there's a little bit of a school of thought that the two don't marry up. You can't keep changing your passwords and have complicated passwords and remember them. So if you encourage people
下周有一个新的应用程序，你突然迷上了它，谁知道它在做什么。所以基本建议，更改你的密码。保持它们非常复杂。不要把它们写在任何人都能找到的地方。是的，像这样的基本事情。尽管现在英国有一些建议实际上建议你不应该再那么频繁地更改密码，因为这使得它变得非常困难，事实上你需要复杂的密码是很重要的。所以如果你也要求人们非常频繁地更改它们，有一种学派认为这两者并不匹配。你不能一直更改密码并拥有复杂的密码并记住它们。所以如果你鼓励人们
to change their passwords too often, then they'll maybe just make them simpler so that they can remember them easier. So they actually have more of a school of thought now that you don't need to change them that often. But what you do need to do is have very different passwords for different types of things. So make sure you have very different passwords for, for instance, your banking or something that is very, potentially has very sensitive information about yourself to an online account for something, I don't know, maybe social media or something where you don't have all that information linked to it. It's almost about understanding the risk. What if someone had that password? What is the worst they could do? Potentially, or if they have my Twitter
太频繁地更改密码，那么他们可能只会让它们变得更简单，以便他们更容易记住。所以他们现在确实有一种学派认为你不需要那么频繁地更改它们。但你需要做的是为不同类型的事情拥有非常不同的密码。所以确保你为，例如，你的银行或其他可能包含关于你自己的非常敏感信息的东西，拥有与在线账户非常不同的密码，比如，我不知道，也许是社交媒体或其他你没有关联所有这些信息的东西。这几乎是关于理解风险。如果有人拥有那个密码会怎样？他们能做的最坏的事情是什么？潜在地，或者如果他们拥有我的Twitter
password, what's the worst they could do? And certainly don't use the same passwords across different types of accounts. That's the big one. Yeah. If they get into your Twitter, you know, and then they can also get into your banking, then it's really not good.
密码，他们能做的最坏的事情是什么？当然不要在不同类型的账户中使用相同的密码。这是最重要的一点。是的。如果他们进入了你的Twitter，你知道，然后他们也可以进入你的银行，那真的不好。
All right, well, that's a lot to worry about. Well, thank you. I hope I've not terrified, aren't they? It's not all bad. We're getting that. Good.
好吧，那有很多值得担心的事情。嗯，谢谢。我希望我没有吓到，不是吗？并非一切都很糟糕。我们正在得到那个。好。
I appreciate that. And thank you so much for being with us today. No problem. No problem at all. Thank you for inviting. So thank you for joining us today on our podcast, Speaking of Psychology.
我很感激。非常感谢你今天和我们在一起。没问题。完全没问题。谢谢你的邀请。所以谢谢你今天加入我们的播客《心理学谈话》。
This is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts, such as APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research, and progress notes, which discusses the practice of psychology. You can find all APA podcasts on iTunes,
这是APA播客网络的一部分，其中包括其他很棒的播客，例如《APA期刊对话》，讨论最新和最令人兴奋的心理学研究，以及《进度记录》，讨论心理学的实践。你可以在iTunes上找到所有APA播客，
Stitcher, and pretty much wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, www. www. speakingof psychology.org to listen to more episodes and to see more resources. sources on the topics we discuss. I'm Kim Mills with the American Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Stitcher，以及几乎任何你获取播客的地方。你也可以访问我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集并查看更多资源，了解我们讨论的主题。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯，这是《心理学谈话》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。